did you know that Microsoft actually
uses Linux to run much of its Cloud
infrastructure and it's not like they're
forced to either before 2015 Microsoft
used to build watered-down versions of
Windows for running networks databases
and the other Cloud infrastructure so
the switch to Linux was very much a
voluntary one while it is surprising
that Microsoft was willing to put aside
their ego and switch to Linux
objectively speaking this switch was not
too surprising given that Linux is
usually the preferred OS for backend
infrastructure
it's simply more stable reliable secure
flexible and much cheaper to operate and
maintain hearing this I don't think
you'd be too surprised to hear that
Microsoft is not the only one that uses
Linux Amazon Dell Facebook Google and
even NASA use Linux for various portions
of their business yet despite its
popularity amongst these institutions
Linux is virtually non-existent amongst
everyday consumers well technically
Android is built on Linux and Android is
the most popular operating system in the
world so you could make that argument
for Linux but I'm talking about the
consumer PC market there 74 use Windows
14 us Mac OS and only five percent use
Linux this isn't to say that Linux isn't
good for desktop use though for decades
hardcore users like programmers
engineers and attack enthusiasts have
not only been using Linux themselves but
they've been preaching about why it's
way better than Windows and a Mac yet no
one else seems to care so if Linux truly
is the objectively better OS and if even
Microsoft uses Linux over Windows why
don't we
one of the top advantages that many
Linux enthusiasts cite is the fact that
Linux is free they argue that instead of
paying 100 for a Windows license you can
pay no money for Linux this way you'd
not only be saving money but you'd also
be getting a superior Os from their
perspective this scenario is clearly a
win-win but from the average consumer's
perspective it's not quite that simple
here's the thing Linux being free
doesn't mean much to the average
consumer because to them Windows and Mac
OS are also free it's not like they have
to go out and buy a license for either
of these either they just go out and buy
the computer and the OS comes along with
the purchase So Not only would the
average consumer not save money by
switching to Linux but they'd also feel
that they're not using something that
they paid it for really the only people
who can save money by using Linux is
people who build their own PCS and PC
Builders are by far the minority within
the PC market
not to mention a substantial portion of
PC Builders are Gamers and windows is
simply the best choice for gaming
because that's what games are built for
and yes there are ways that you can run
Windows games on Linux but this kind of
defeats the entire purpose of Linux one
of the biggest advantages of Linux is
that it can run many things better
natively but games are not usually one
of those things because they're
specifically coded to run on Windows
also if someone is willing to spend a
thousand dollars or thousands of dollars
on a gaming PC I highly doubt that the
cost of a Windows license is a serious
consideration even if it was if there's
Savvy enough to build a PC there
probably Savvy enough to migrate windows
from an old computer or just hired it
and that brings us to our next point
which is that getting windows for free
is extraordinarily easy while Windows is
not free on paper Microsoft has gone out
of their way to make sure that you can
get it for free if you want to you don't
even need to Pirate it you can literally
die downloaded straight from Microsoft's
website and install it onto a new
computer using a USB stick also there's
literally no consequences for not
activating Windows you get 30 days to
activate it but even if you don't the
only thing you lose is your ability to
personalize in other words you don't
lose any functionality whatsoever so for
end users whether you're buying a
pre-built or building your own PC Linux
offers virtually no Financial benefit
someone who does financially benefit
from Tuesday Linux however is
institutions
schools universities companies and
computer manufacturers all have to pay
for Windows licenses now I'm sure they
don't pay anywhere near as much as 100
per license given that they probably get
some sort of bulk discount but even if
it's 30 or 40 dollars per license when
these institutions are ordering tens of
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of computers Windows does end up costing
them several hundred thousand dollars if
not Millions so switching to Linux could
be a smart choice but this option
quickly becomes impossible when you
realize that none of your customers
students or employees actually know how
to use Linux
foreign
one of the biggest obstacles for Linux
adoption is that it's just not that easy
to use Linux uis have made strides
within the past several years especially
Ubuntu but some level of familiarity
with the command line is still extremely
helpful when it comes to using Linux to
many Tech enthusiasts this is what makes
Linux so great instead of having to deal
with generic user interfaces that are
built for General consumption you can
use the command line to do very specific
tasks while this is great for people who
are comfortable with the command line
this just seems completely unnecessary
to people who aren't the customizability
and flexibility that the command line
unlocks are simply not applicable to the
average person virtually all these
people are primarily doing extremely
generic tasks like working on word docs
and Excel sheets or replying to emails
and the freedom that the command line
offers doesn't seem like a freedom at
all for them the command line simply
comes off as an unnecessarily
complicated way to accomplish extremely
straightforward tasks even for the
people who could benefit from the
command line more times than not they
don't want to spend time learning about
it because it seems super daunting they
often feel that they need to know coding
to use the command line and they often
fear that they're one wrong command away
from corrupting something and destroying
their computer this is especially true
when you're running a command using
administrative Authority it just feels
like you're messing with something that
you shouldn't be messing with aside from
having to deal with the command line
with Linux you also have to deal with
installing everything manually once
again this is actually one of the
advantages of Linux Linux comes with
virtually no bloatware so you can
install only what you need this is one
of the reasons why Linux machines with
the same specs tend to run faster and
smoother than Windows machines but the
average user does not always view the
situation in the same light for them all
this means is that Linux does not work
out of the box and that's not an
advantage that's a disadvantage many of
them are actually like much of the
software that Linux users would classify
as a bloatware take Mac OS for example
Macs generally come pre-installed with
Apple TV APPA music iCloud FaceTime and
iMessage for a power user who's only
looking to use their Mac for production
purposes like coding software like Apple
TV and iCloud may seem completely
useless they're probably never going to
open Apple TV on this machine and
therefore prefer GitHub over iCloud but
for the everyday user they may love that
their photos are automatically synced to
iCloud and that they can text through
iMessage for them all this pre-installed
software isn't bloatware it's what makes
a computer functional out of the box as
Apple likes to call it it just works
both the windows and the Mac OS just
work Linux on the other hand doesn't and
even though that's what makes Linux so
flexible customizable and free most
people simply don't care enough about
that to learn the command line or a new
OS
foreign
users will swear by Linux the bottom
line is that the average person simply
has no need for it in fact even power
users don't really need it simply
because Mac OS and windows have gotten
so good at emulating the best features
of Linux take coding for example one of
the main reasons that developers love
Linux is because it's based on Unix Unix
is an OS that's specifically designed
with programmers in mind Windows is not
based on Unix so it often makes sense to
choose Linux over windows but something
that is based on Unix is Mac OS so not
only does Mac offer many of the coding
advantages at Linux but it's also more
user friendly and Polished this is why
Mac OS is extremely popular amongst
developers globally the Mac only has 8.9
the market share but amongst developers
it has 44 market share aside from most
people not having any need for Linux
they also find that Linux actively makes
them less productive for example not all
Linux distros come with Wi-Fi drivers
which means that you'll have to manually
install drivers just to connect to the
internet but at least that's a one-time
issue something that you'll have to
constantly deal with is a lack of
support even something as rudimentary
and basic as Microsoft Office is not
natively supported on Linux so you'll
have to jump through a bunch of
loopholes just to get access to basic
software this same rule also applies to
software like Photoshop Premiere Pro
Autodesk Inventor and basically anything
else that doesn't directly involve
coding but at least you can make the
software work by jumping through a few
Hoops there are several websites and
software that simply will not work on
Linux whatsoever for example nothing to
do with Pearson Education Works if
you're a student and have a bunch of
classes that use Pearson this makes
Linux completely unviable so that's
pretty much all of the objective reasons
that the PC community at large hasn't
adopted Linux linux's free nature isn't
all that helpful like command line and
you why it is rather daunting and Linux
often poses a lot more challenges than
solutions for most people but there is a
subjective side to all of this as well
and I don't think this video would be
complete if we didn't discuss that the
truth is that Linux comes along with a
negative social stigma usually Linux is
associated with the Nerds and the broke
people in terms of social Prestige Mac
would probably be first place Windows
would be second place and Linux would be
last place so why would the average
person want to go out of their way to
downgrade themselves socially when they
can just get a Mac or Windows machine
the answer is that there's no reason and
that's what Linux adoption is where it's
at today
foreign
while Linux may be superior in certain
use cases almost all of these use cases
are professional they involve databases
networks and cloud computing which are
all things that the average person will
never deal with from the back end also
even amongst the people who do use Linux
for professional purposes I bet most of
them have a Windows or Mac machine at
home for personal use cases while there
will be some enthusiasts that argue that
Linux is better for personal use as well
this is simply not true and honestly I
think a lot of these guys have an
ulterior motive many of them use Linux
not because it's superior but because of
ideological reasons they're usually
anti-big Tech and they think that open
source projects like Linux could be
supported and developed as much as
possible and this is usually the core
reason that they're so Pro Linux but as
for the rest of us well we usually just
don't care as Mary Bellman once said it
people don't spend their lives trying to
get a look at what's behind the curtain
they like the curtain it provides them
ability Comfort definition and within
the PC market Mac OS and windows are
that curtain have you ever used Linux
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think the Linux deserves more
credit and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community suggest for
your video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one